ادى نحو 120 الف فلسطينيين صلاه عيد الفطر
السعيد في المسجد الاقصى المبارك وذلك وسط
اجراءات امنيه فرضها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على المداخل المؤديه للبلده القديمه في
القدس وعلى ابواب المسجد الاقصى وقد ملات
تكبيرات العيد اجواء المدينه وازقتها حيث
وصل المصلون من القدس وضواحيها ومن القرى
والبلدات العربيه داخل الخط الاخضر مهللين
ومسبحين بحمد الله وكانت مدينه القدس قد
عاشت اياما عصيبه خلال شهر رمضان الفضيل
لاسيما بعد ان اقتحم جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الاقصى اكثر من مره ومنعوا
المصلين من الاعتكاف فيه
كما ادى الاف الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه
شعائر صلاه عيد الفطر السعيد في الساحات
العامه بمحافظات القطاع واعرب المصلون عن
املهم ان يحل الامن والاستقرار والسلام
على الشعب الفلسطيني وشعوب العالم كما
طالبوا بالحريه للاسرى ورفع الحصار
الاسرائيلي عن قطاع غزه